yo what's the deal man it's your boy
jeezy jesus rolled out now come check me
out on the bootleg cash show
all right man look bullet cat podcast
bullet cav show special guest in here
yes sir one of the hardest uh young
artists out of la this guy's worldwide
right now man oh geezy world
gzworld the album comes why i don't know
if you're watching this it might already
be out because the [ __ ] comes out
tomorrow night oh geezy is here
welcome i'm here man i feel good man my
album's out it should feel crazy my
first solo album hey congrats bro and i
feel like um
this has been
like long awaited yeah
heavily anticipated yes sir like your
your fan group like like first of all
you have like a cool following low key
no doubt
you know what i'm saying and um
it's just been dope to see your growth
from the shoreline days and just the
business moves you've been making and i
feel like he was always had like a boss
state of mind even when like i would
interview all you guys together like you
know what i'm saying yeah no doubt i
feel like i've always been like
the head and the head of everything like
i always i
i i for sure think of myself as like a
boss so i've always been like creatively
and just in charge of all the business
overall yeah man and like you know from
the weed [ __ ] to the merch [ __ ] to just
everything just everything and i just
became a partner at a restaurant we're
about to open up midisco spot right yeah
why the east coast fight that's about to
go crazy where's it at uh right there on
sunset la cienega inside the fred
seagull oh yeah so you so okay what made
you pick marisco says like the the red i
mean obviously you love some some
seafood but yeah i'm mexican so that's
like yeah it's only right
yeah what's your go-to if you go to the
modisco spot ceviche oh ceviche of
course but what kind of ceviche uh the
shrimp okay okay
you know sometimes you go to like
vallarta and they got like you get like
the cups of that [ __ ]
i'm like let me just try all of them and
there's the green one that is hot as
[ __ ]
i'll be [ __ ] up every time i'm here i
grew up i grew up on ceviche so my
grandma don't even know like she's been
making me ceviche my whole life so she
don't even know i got the restaurant
right now you're gonna surprise her yeah
hell yeah that's bad
just take over like hey i'm gonna take
you to eat now by the way grandma this
is my [ __ ] yeah for sure yeah
actually too man it's like on the way to
beverly hills it's right on sunset yeah
yeah i was gonna say it sounds like a
you know it might not i thought you were
going to say the valley or some [ __ ] no
it's going to be nice as [ __ ] damn she
gonna have the boujee
seafood towers and champagne
see oh yeah come on that's date night
yeah day hey date night and sunday we
going up off the hangovers everybody oh
you're gonna have like the day party
popping yeah come on everybody gotta
pull up we're gonna be going up
watch out playhouse
penthouse where's the penthouse club i'm
going to start selling this on sunday
sections
playhouse is closed right yeah r.i.p to
playhouse i think the last time i was at
playhouse you were actually there during
your birthday probably yeah yeah yeah um
man so your album is obviously uh you
know i know it's been getting worked on
for a minute but you got some crazy
features
uh just give me the rundown of who i was
on the project man man i got uh yg i got
the baby of course that was the first
single drop crazy record hey boogie
video out now just came out the a boogie
meek me a boogie it's called keeper
y'all go check that out i got blue bucks
i had to do something for the city
i had to put blue books on it and that's
a banger that's one of my favorites on
there and i got the little uh somali
homie from ohio his name o faygo little
faygo yeah does he drink vega mo faygo
mo favorite oh mo fayo mo faygo yeah he
do drink [ __ ] that's that's what he
said when that when his verse started he
go hell yeah that's my name what the
[ __ ] i'm pouring in
so some people don't know like if you
grew up in the 90s
as a caucasian i always associated faygo
before sipping i always associated faygo
with an insane clown boss
i know subway and st clown posse because
my uncle used to listen to that my uncle
put me up on a game with everything i
know all hip-hop yeah just listening so
he used to have two liters of fago oh
yeah was your uncle like a juggalo
yeah oh damn yeah he he [ __ ] heavy
does he have a hatchet man tattoo no he
got a hatchet man uh oh yeah your
uncle's in yeah yeah gatherings all that
yo
let me tell you something when i was a
kid
i went to some icp shows cause like
other artists i [ __ ] would be on the
shows
but their fans are [ __ ] they have a
real real cult following that's like the
definition of a co-following they got
the tattoos
and i think they try to uh
like give them like gang and junkies
yeah no they did they actually were
officially uh on the fbi list of gangs
yeah that's crazy
yeah nah they used to launch um two
leaders of faygo into the crowd yeah
i've seen their videos i used to have a
wrestling game all types no that [ __ ] is
crazy
who would have thought that your uncle
would be a juggalo that's crazy
yo if you ever get offered the bag to go
to the gathering turn it down a lot you
don't want to go over there
stay away they got drug bridge there's
like a bridge
at the gathering of the juggalos where
it's just like a free market for dru
it's a lot of bo a lot of tweakers and a
lot of [ __ ] white trash bro
gathering of the juggalos they tried to
book me to dj they said nah come on bro
what the [ __ ] i look like what's that
gonna do to my brand
yo man i was at the gathering of the
juggalos dj and [ __ ] playing [ __ ]
i don't even know what they would want
to eat cod mouth kings or something come
on okay now i've been saying that uh 36
i'll be always doing that [ __ ] yeah dj
paul yeah yeah yeah i [ __ ] dj paul
heavy that's why he's a legend man
paul's a legend
um how did you and the baby link up
because i remember seeing that
and being like oh [ __ ]
that's a big move
as your first single solo i mean you've
been putting out some stuff on youtube
the edd [ __ ] you put out during the
pandemic spoke to my heart you know what
i'm saying um
hey that [ __ ] got tucked down so fast
did it yeah i think i did like two or
three million views in like two weeks
and it got tucked down but i just said
all my homies
back of america uh copyrighted that [ __ ]
yeah cause you were in front of the bfa
right yeah i was in the boa with the
cards yeah all my homies are still
bumping that [ __ ] though um but yeah
that's that song we'll get to that song
in a bit but no but but for you to have
like your first official single with one
of the biggest artists in the world like
the baby like i just thought that was
such a a power move yeah yeah yeah i
know i knew what i was doing that was a
strategic movie for me i was
put putting everything uh
in play for the future was he tapped in
with like your movement and what you had
going on or was it more like hey look i
got a bag for you come do this record no
it was more like you know we sent him
the record and then and then he was like
bro [ __ ] with this i [ __ ] with the sound
so we gonna do it
did you have to pay uh yeah
we paid him a little back yeah i mean
you know he's getting a big bag yeah
yeah he might be getting a smaller bag
now a little big bag do you hear me no
what what what did you think when you
saw everything that happened at rolling
loud you know what i'm saying because i
think like
i was there watching the set i was uh i
was there too i was turnt up i was on
shrooms
he was on shows yeah running around
backstage yeah i was running around
backstage drunk so i don't even know
what's going on yeah it was fun i was
like blacked out in that [ __ ] if you
see me at rolling low you did not see me
what i loved about
hot 97 didn't take him off the show
which is
yeah because i feel like all the other
people who did that it was it just
seemed like it was very like
not in not genuine if you know what i'm
saying like it was just like the thing
to do for some free promo for your
festival
yeah that's crazy i was on another
festival where i think he was supposed
to be on and they had to took him off
i mean crazy that whole situation crazy
he's a good dude i always tell everybody
i know baby for a minute like i don't
think he's a hateful guy i think he's a
good person you know at the end of the
day [ __ ] [ __ ] up you know so
players [ __ ] up too man um and then a
boogie hey boogie's a you know again
that's you know
bronx finest right there hybrids you
know like like uh new york to l.a i mean
i know you guys are label mates you know
what i mean but how was that how was
that connection man sent him a record i
was like because i wanted a boogie on
that record so we sent him the record
and uh he was [ __ ] with it because
anytime you send an artist to record
there's always a chance like
i feel like money is not the motive for
almost everybody especially when you're
at that level hey boogie the baby
you gotta really [ __ ] with the record
genuinely so
yeah so when you're on that level you
could
because even i be turning down features
all day like i almost don't take no
money for features because i only do
features of people i [ __ ] with
so i'll be turning money down all day
they've been asking me to do features
since i started i've never done a paid
feature really you've never done a paid
feature you won only how much did you
get paid uh
it was it was like a favor for a favor
type thing too i did someone's artist
feature so when he took like five bands
for it oh yeah that's that's a deal but
they'd be offering me 15 20 30 bans like
and i don't do it why did you kind of
did you just like make a conscious
decision to like not water down your
[ __ ] because you know there's rappers
rappers
i see rappers will be doing features
with everybody talking about a thousand
two thousand dollar features like no
hell no
no yes some people that's like their
business like yo shout out to boosie
boozy will go to any city he's going to
and post it on instagram
but you see boo boo see like that but
that's like his thing yeah that's his
thing
it's different it's different but you
see that's why other people try to do it
like boosting but you're not doing it
like him and you're not boosting so now
he's smart man because i think that
that's like a big mistake that a lot of
young artists make is is thinking about
the short dollar and not the long play
yeah for sure i'm thinking about the
future everything i do yeah because if
your brand is exclusive if you're not
[ __ ] with everything like
it makes it that much bigger of a deal
when you drop oh yeah but if you're like
out here holding yourself out to
everybody who's got a bag yeah it's
stephen thomas like it's a lot of people
i do [ __ ] with and i don't do features
with them just because i know like i
don't want to water down my brain so i'm
like yo i gotta even though you're the
homie i gotta like make sure that my
brain stay say where it's at i gotta
keep my brain on a pedestal that's smart
man that's smart um
what about like what what
you know i think fashion wise you're
[ __ ] you know you know for for being
fly as [ __ ]
come on yeah are you getting into uh the
clothing game at all yeah yeah yeah i've
been doing merch i feel like i mean no
no your merch is crazy i feel like my
merch is beyond merch already like it's
past ele it's already elevated past that
so it's like a real fashion line but i
want to take it to like a high fashion
like off-white type [ __ ]
so i just dropped this with asap in one
of the uh yeah shout out to asap yeah
yeah it's a mourinho infantry ltx collab
so we just dropped this and it's going
crazy this this really my first collab
with like
a bigger brand
so
and i've been wearing his [ __ ] for
[ __ ] years already and i've been
[ __ ] with him as like a person in
general so it was only right [ __ ] just
came full circle
talk to me about um
you know
coming out of a group right shoreline
mafia i feel like kind of paved the way
for a lot of the uh la [ __ ] that's going
on right now for sure most days um
you know i think of like draco greedo
and you guys that kind of like laid the
foundation for a lot of the scene right
now you know what i mean
um
how hard was it for you to kind of pivot
away from the group or was it kind of
always in the in the plans because
anybody was like a fan of what you guys
are doing
you know
you you were i mean i mean shout out to
everybody in the group but but i think
it was obvious that like eventually you
had to go solo or at least i feel like
it was it was never in the plan it's
just like you know people people grow
like and just being on tour being on the
road just figuring out life like i'm
getting older i had my kid
when i had my kid i was like you know
what this like maybe it's time for me to
go do my own thing
so but everybody felt like that
everybody was like yeah we want to do
our own thing yeah i think too when you
got so many people involved in trying to
get to the same thing right everybody's
got to be aligned everyone's energy's
got to match each other
everyone's effort
and
you know that's why it's so hard for
groups to work man yeah yeah so you
gotta think it's four different opinions
four different energies four
personalities that's a lot that's a lot
going on and all four y'all got to be on
the same page when you go touch that
stage or you guys go do an interview on
a travel like
traveling and touring is like even
though it looked fun that's just hard
it's super hard work so
just just to keep that momentum and that
energy up take a lot of work so if
you're not all the way invested i was
gonna say when you guys were all on tour
together did you did was that like
because i feel like when you tour with
someone you're kind of living with them
right exactly so when that happens
living with people you get to see like
like god this might not work exactly
that's like that's like oh yeah all
y'all broke [ __ ] be fighting
with your mama
because you living with people man it's
like yeah that's not working you think
that that was kind of like a eye-opener
for you when you guys toured like okay
maybe we don't get along like we thought
we did or yeah for sure that was that
was definitely it had to be like one of
the a big factor yeah yeah oh yeah uh
how's fatherhood treating you man good
man i love it you're saying you have a
celebrity baby yeah yeah he famous he
got his own instagram yeah he got his
own instagram
what the [ __ ] is his instagram i think
uh sincere just look up sincere my [ __ ]
yes yeah what's but like you know
obviously
being a dad man how's that how has that
just changed you as a dude man so like i
said that's one of the the main things
that changed me and my whole mind about
everything because even besides a group
like i used to want to look out for all
my friends like
kind of be like a
father figure type role you feel me just
try to put everyone up on game once my
son was born i was like yo all my focus
and attention has to be on him i can't
try to look out for no one i can't be
investing my time and energy into nobody
else besides him like i got to focus on
him and myself yeah because i feel like
you know when you make it into the rap
game it's like all your homies make it
too low-key yeah yeah for sure and that
can also get
unproductive distracting
bad for your pockets
you know what i mean it's like yo if
ever if you're gonna be around what are
you doing for me yeah are you the barber
are you the road manager are you
security you know
you just can't be kicking it we just
can't be 2k homies not for real like
like four or five months into my son
being born i purchased my first home too
yeah so i just feel like
once once he was about to be born like i
started getting my head on straight like
started figuring out what i needed to do
and where i wanted to be and then you
purchased a home on your neck yeah come
on had some that's a house in palmdale
at least right yeah the ie or something
yeah corona and get you a house with
that chain
um we were talking earlier about your
fan base being so crazy uh what's like
the wildest
fan experience you've had whether it's
some like weirdo groupie [ __ ] or like
just you got you've had to have some
weird [ __ ] happen like i think some of
the weirdest is when like people like
try to follow you when you leave the
venue and [ __ ] like guys be trying like
why are you trying to follow me what are
you thinking yeah man babies are real
like what do you think i'm gonna invite
you to ruin a kick it or something
that's strange
that's like the weirdest [ __ ] though
really you're like like just men male
groupies yeah just males like trying to
[ __ ] kick it tough have you ever had
to like has it like did ever get like
out of control or out of hand where like
yo what the [ __ ] bro like no not really
because i i be understanding where they
coming from they just like
they super big fans so i'd be trying to
help my keep my composure hey
interrupting the interview to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks now
as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying ooh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are the outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you
these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20 off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kevin checkout save 20
how big of a deal is it like
representing
you know because at the end of the day
man when we think of
mexicans right we don't think of in hip
hop we think of like at least how i grew
up it was hey man little rod mc magic uh
you know going down the list right but
i don't think that there's really been
like a mexican artist
that's really dropped music that i've
you know as as a rapper that's like on
the level that you're on that also isn't
exclusive to mexican people if that
makes sense because you know if you're
listening to little rob you either had
to be from like a mexican area like i'm
from phoenix so i'm like yeah not
[ __ ] summer nights is my [ __ ] but
like some kid from like you know
baton rouge ain't gonna yeah you know
what i'm saying but you're making like
you know on on on a very big stage and
kind of i feel good i think you feel
amazing like i'm making history and i
made a whole new wave and i see a lot of
people following the suit and a lot of
kids they got so much potential doing
what i'm doing
no the i think the the shout out to
everyone um
suede swifty blue i mean there's so many
dope mexican rappers that are killing it
right now
i'm happy as [ __ ] that i i'm at the
forefront of all this you feel me like
i'm really making history and then they
gonna continue making history
yeah do you feel like you're kind of
like because you are kind of like
leading the way low-key for a lot of
people because you're on the major label
you got the big features you got the big
records you got the big you got the tour
you got the fans you know what i'm
saying swag man if anything i'm the
blueprint y'all gotta like really pay
attention to what i do and and just try
to do it better
when you yeah because i think with what
you do with your brand with the with the
merch with the wii just with everything
i got to be exclusive that's all i'm
saying just how i was talking about the
features man all that feature [ __ ]
that's out the window like
it you need i feel like you know when
it's really a good decision and when
it's not like it needs to be thirsty for
features i'm like nah you gotta be
exclusive yeah i think you know what
they're gonna take your exclusiveness
all the way there it is there it is um
if if so so maybe someone's never heard
you right and they get your album or
they see this i'ma go check out gzworld
what's the one song you you wouldn't
want them to go straight to man
let me see probably the blue book [ __ ]
you feel me i i love that song like the
moment i made it
i was like yeah that's a banger right
here so that's one of my personal
favorites my second personal favorite is
poep
and i i wouldn't uh send like someone
that's barely first listening to me i'll
send that to like all my organic fans my
day one fan
yeah poe
it's um it's a section eight beat he
went a little baby producer so a it's an
atlanta sound and it's me like just
[ __ ] with new sounds so i want all my
fans to go listen to that [ __ ] yeah i
mean you're obviously someone who's kind
of uh been associated with with with
sipping and [ __ ] like that
um
do you kind of feel like that's a
double-edged sword to like because you
know there's a dark side to that yeah
yeah it's a dark side of everything
though alcohol to everything oh for sure
except for maybe not weed i don't know
what the dark side the weed is except
for maybe getting fat and eating too
much
hey man it's a dark day once you get too
fat man or you eat too much of an edible
and then you lose your [ __ ] mind and
then jump off of a building or something
but now but just the sipping thing like
like you said it's a dark side i think
you know what's crazy is it the money
bag yo wrecker wakisha that's just going
crazy it's a very like if you listen to
what he's saying it's like literally
the the
the like the predicament every person
who gets on lean is in
it tastes good it makes you feel good
but damn amazing man but don't do it but
[ __ ] have you [ __ ] up yeah have you
super [ __ ] up have you not on [ __ ]
like
when i would say maleen i can't i
haven't sibling in in months
congrats man that's big when i was
sibling i probably
i haven't seen lean since my birthday
last year so it's probably about to be a
year
that's big man yeah hell yeah um that
[ __ ] really slowed you the [ __ ] down and
then besides it's slowing you down what
it's doing to your body you're just
taking years off your life like with
anything any vice you feel me alcohol
all that so the whole quarantine i was i
was being healthy mentally
physically everything so i feel like my
head got clear and and that that's what
helped me do this album and be in this
good space i'm in right now so yeah for
so anyone watching this right now man
stay off the lean man
stay off everything as much as you can
man it's cool just smoke some of his
weed because his weed is good
go get that exotic shot after the
anxiety yeah otx yeah only the exclusive
did you have a like a low point with
with the lean [ __ ] like a scary scary
situation that maybe made you rethink
whether or not you wanted to [ __ ] with
that nah not with lean it's just like
with everything i feel like
drinking lean pills partying and
everything it's just like that should
get depressing
like you can't be doing it all the time
it just slow you down like and me since
i am a businessman i have so much [ __ ]
to do i can't i'm like yo i can't just
be high
hey what what do you think attributes to
your
mentality being so young like was it
something growing up was it your family
because like i think maybe seeing mama
because it's not like i had i didn't
have no father figure like so i think
maybe just seeing my mom work 24 7 like
all [ __ ] day just seeing how hard she
worked made me want to be like yo
i wanna i wanna
be a hard worker too
you feel me but i'm not about to do no
regular [ __ ]
yeah i just think like there's not a lot
of people that are your age that think
the way you think it's very rare i don't
know what it is maybe you know what it
what it might be too just seeing like
all these other artists like the few
that are like me and just hearing them
talking that's just motivating so you
know like we got a big we got a big
influence on on all the youth who
motivated you uh man hearing nipsey talk
like harry nipsey i used to watch all
his interviews and just hearing him talk
you could just tell like how different
someone is yep he's wired different man
yeah you can see like where their head
is that and it's crazy yeah i think
nipsey influenced so many people hell
yeah you know think of yj but yg's doing
you know why he's doing the weed thing
he's doing the he's got his shoes his
clothing line you know exactly exactly
i think like nipsey's influence will
just live forever from this point
because you're gonna influence somebody
exactly you know what i mean and and so
on and so forth so
how's your relationship with um you know
with all the other guys in shoreline
right now you still talk to phoenix or
is it just everyone's just kind of doing
their own thing everybody just do their
own thing i don't really keep
communication with nobody it's not it's
not beef but it's like it is what it is
it is what it is was understood don't
got to be explained it just ain't work
out yeah i mean that's that [ __ ] happens
man it happens i should like a real
relationship like
you feel me what's it like you know
being um because i'm you're in a
relationship right yeah yeah and and and
i think you're pretty public with your
relationship right
as far as like yeah like how is it hard
to to do
that and also be a [ __ ] rap star that
girls love you bro like women love
ogeezy you know what i'm saying oh man
they love you bro so fresh and fly how
tough is that you know cause i i know
what it's like just being me and dealing
with my wife you know i mean we take we
take it for what it is man we we me and
my girl got to embrace the fact that
girls love me because we out here um
selling eyelashes and lip gloss and all
that so yeah i was going to get to that
you feel me i i'm like molding my girl
into a business woman herself you feel
me yeah talk about whose idea was it to
do the eyelashes and lip gloss
so it was
it like came came about together like
she was getting eyelashes and i'm like
yo what's the price on that we start
talking and chopping it up and i'm like
yo we need to do this and then she
creatively designed all the girl stuff
she she's super creative so she'd be
coming up with everything and i'd just
be throwing the ideas out there like
what we could do and then she [ __ ]
put the stamp on it oh she's the first
rapper with his own eyelashes yeah come
on and they look nice as [ __ ] yeah i
gotta go cop slam jesus
ladies tap in tap the [ __ ] in and you
got lip gloss lip gloss
that's like mc magic pulled up here once
and this [ __ ] had his own makeup
palettes hey man i'm gonna get i'm gonna
get into all that man you see
you see what um what's your name kylie
kylie jenner and rihanna's a billionaire
off of makeup bro not even the music the
[ __ ] i'm talking about like the music is
just like a vessel for everything else
yeah
what about um you say you bought your
first house you're gonna try to get just
into some like more like real estate
[ __ ] or yeah so what i'm gonna do this
uh this
in a few months probably because i've
been getting some bags man it's just
opening back up i'm about to upgrade
hospital i'm about to give myself a way
bigger house my house already big i'm
going to get a way bigger house and use
that one as a rental property just smart
man just keep doing that [ __ ] over and
over exactly exactly just keep upgrading
how it says i might keep this one
because it's big as [ __ ]
but you don't know what type of money
i'll be making next year so we're gonna
see he's like yeah we might hold off i
mean we might really really really
upgrade yeah you know
is it like for you like obviously you
know being from la and you know i think
we've seen a lot um of people
maybe get caught up in some [ __ ]
being at home like obviously rest in
peace to nipsey um you know x was in his
neighborhood in florida when he got hit
like do you
like
stay out the [ __ ] way man and not
because you ain't real or whatever but
like something like you say you got a
family and you know i feel like you get
more hate probably from home than
anywhere else usually when you're
popping like that i'd definitely be
trying to stay out the way but then i
got my my moments i'm like man let's go
everywhere everywhere in the city you
feel me but i be definitely staying at a
[ __ ] like
like my mind to focus on business to to
be involved in some [ __ ]
definitely i'd be trying to stay out the
way that's smart man oh yeah and you got
security obviously yeah if so yeah
people it's all right they have security
hell yeah you got yourself man i got no
security well you're a [ __ ] idiot or
you ain't popping enough to [ __ ]
never have to worry about security yeah
yeah you gotta have some kids six nines
i ain't got securities like [ __ ]
because you can't afford it anymore
cause that money's running now
being a mexican dude he's mexican hey
hey he could he i'm glad he dropped the
bag because now i'm the one yeah he
[ __ ] the whole [ __ ] off so he
six nine left the whole [ __ ] for you
like man
it's like whatever he did didn't even
happen because he was snitching it was
erased yeah race it's my time now it's
your turn it was meant to be
it was definitely meant to be man um are
you already kind of working on new music
or are you just focused on dropping this
album pushing it and then i'm about to
drop this out of him and then i think i
need to get right back in the studio man
i need i think i might need to give you
a gz world part two this year yeah
no no not this year maybe at the top of
next year
um you did we were talking about the edd
song earlier so i want to address the
song because i saw this song and i was
like this is one of the most
beautifully ignorant things that speak
to this time
because everyone i [ __ ] know the meet
and greets people was coming up having
me sign their edd cards
that's amazing yeah i just thought it
was like the perfect anthem for everyone
in my life that i knew was just
people were crazy
i got homies still getting to it i'm
like bro chill like but now
[ __ ] are really running it up
yeah yeah yeah i'm sure everybody uh
well if nothing bad happening i'm sure
everybody else enjoyed [ __ ]
coronavirus y'all was sitting at home
just getting money kicking him man even
if you weren't doing the scam and [ __ ]
even if you just had a lot of people who
had part-time jobs got fired and was
making more money staying at home like
this
like this piece of [ __ ] right here
i know a bunch of people that was
working they just had no work no more
had money he was getting paid am i going
to go to mcdonald's to work 40 hours or
am i going to stay home and make more
money
and [ __ ] play 2k hell yeah
hopefully a lot of people use it as an
opportunity to like start a business nah
or take some risks they bought some good
gucci though some good louie
i don't think
i don't think nobody used it as a
[ __ ] opportunity yeah you're probably
right money y'all was [ __ ] up i seen
everybody buying the more expensive weed
i was like yo i had cookies this one i
got y'all cookies and a link yeah i had
a good friend i have a good friend that
is gonna see this and know everyone
knows what i'm talking about but
he's been doing his thing with that and
uh
he's always like yo
all you got is designer like
you'll come to la and just go and just
[ __ ] off like 20 30 bands on designer
and then be like yo kev i'm trying to
make some business moves what do i do
and i'm like bro
stop buying [ __ ] dolce and cabana
[ __ ] button ups
somewhere man like like yeah like figure
out like buy some bitcoin dude literally
anything else i just got some crypto too
oh you did like what are you into yeah
what the [ __ ] did i get ethereum i got
darian is smart i got some etherium i
think i put 15 bands in it and i let
that [ __ ] rock and i did that [ __ ]
during quarantine my [ __ ] went all the
way down to like [ __ ] but but you
just got to not sell yeah exactly i was
like that's people are stupid because
i'm like that's money that i'ma spend on
some dumb [ __ ] right and the thing is is
like when [ __ ] goes down like that you
buy more you don't sell that [ __ ] came
back so now exactly it just went up this
past this is this anytime with this
crypto [ __ ] cause i do the crypto [ __ ]
anytime everyone's sad because [ __ ] took
took a [ __ ] and you see you need to buy
some money you buy more literally that's
what i did
i was like all right i'm either going to
sell and eat this l or i'm going to
double down and buy more because it's
going to come up
so yeah anyone watching this
if you're not a [ __ ] and you actually
have money in crypto first of all if you
yeah what you doing well first of all if
you if you if you have that much money
in it and then you like panic and get
sad when it dips you're you're broke you
shouldn't have put the money in there
anyway because you couldn't afford it
you said you should only do it when you
got money to play with exactly exactly
unlike what about are you into sports no
i'm not internal spoilers okay how's it
say we could have some i got to put you
on some sports games you know what i'm
saying
um well look man the album uh
body of work you got some crazy features
on it um how big of a deal was it for
you to do a record with yg man
i know you guys share some people on the
team yeah yeah yeah we got the same uh
managers now yeah but um yeah yeah it
was a big moment because that's like
that's what we grew up listening to when
i was in high school was listening to yg
non-stop so for us to come together and
do a song and for it to be that hard you
feel me that was a big moment when you
first started dropping [ __ ] i remember
me and dj head we'd be listening to your
guys [ __ ] on soundcloud
and we'd be like jesus christ
can we they need to get someone to mix
and master this [ __ ] yeah
ain't no [ __ ] engineer
so i used to just hit record we used to
use garageband for the i think we did
mustang on garageband on garageband
that's a platinum song right yeah hell
yeah we did musty on garageband and then
we did it it sounded like it out the
apartment
out the apartment
that's right remember we saw hey these
guys just got up some of the mixer
bastards and [ __ ] this [ __ ] would be way
way it sounded cool to me because i know
the difference but now you know the
difference because all your records
sound crispy as [ __ ] now yeah
you know your superstar who who's the
artist that if you if you could like
pick two or three artists to work with
no matter who it is man let's say you
you know you had a genie bottle who
would it be future for sure i always say
future like
i want to work for i've done some [ __ ]
with him but i want to do like a whole
project or something in the future just
because i listen to him on the daily
like right i've been listening to the
same [ __ ] future mixtapes for the
past [ __ ] five years yeah i mean he
had that run like
yeah family monster and all that yeah so
so yeah definitely future drake come on
i got to [ __ ] drake
who was
man i want to do some [ __ ] with like uh
money back yo for sure money back yo is
that guy right now he's going up i've
seen he just sold the most albums this
year which is crazy which is awesome
that's crazy congrats yeah and like he
was not you know the thing i like about
yo is like this is consistency every
year he was just leveling up exactly
when his when all those like federal
mixtapes was coming out i was like how
is he not one of the biggest artists
because he was gassing he's just been
leveling up non-stop you know okay
that's what life is put you on the
wakisha remix bro hey come on let's do
it yeah yeah that's why keisha is crazy
okay how did you feel when you heard
that song did you were you like yeah i
loved it
you know what cause my girl plays the
the regular shanty [ __ ] all [ __ ] day
every day so i love that song to begin
with when i heard him come on and i'm
like yes like it's a it's a like a male
version so the shanty [ __ ]
i was like
about this all day there it is man look
go get the album yes uh
i know things are kind of in limbo with
like live shows right now are you
planning on doing any shows i'm about to
uh do a tour i'm gonna announce it real
soon but i got a tour in november
so the tour is not till november yeah
hopefully the world will be
non-delta yeah no did you catch did you
catch the rona ever yeah twice you
caught it twice but i was cold like each
time you were cool yeah are you
vaccinated no are you gonna get the
[ __ ] jab uh i think if they if they
start like you already see what new york
is doing so if [ __ ] um tell me yo you
gotta get vaccinated fly do shows i
gotta do it yeah i gotta go get this you
just haven't got it cause you just not
not like you just i just fell into it
yeah because because my body's obviously
takes that [ __ ] in like and you've had
it twice so you have all the antibodies
and [ __ ] that's what i'm saying my body
takes it in like whatever so i'm like
[ __ ]
yeah man i can wait i can hold off a
little bit i just had it once because
they probably keep coming up with new
[ __ ] uh vaccinations every [ __ ]
week or something something like that
now they're saying you got to get a
booster shot let me get the let me get
the later version he said let me get
[ __ ] let me get this after you guys
figure this [ __ ] out or something yeah
yeah let me get the [ __ ] the the fda
well now it's fda approved so now you
can get it you know what i mean hey
appreciate you for pulling up
oh geez
jeezy world let's go